for you like being a CEO being kind of
the leader of the crew what what were
some of the things that you kind of had
to you know because I feel like we saw
Dex kind of struggle with his
sobriety you know staying in right right
state of mind and it seems like he's
doing really well now for you was that
something that was like
um hard to deal with like because you
know sometimes when I've I had a lot of
people in my life that have dealt with
addiction you know what I mean I know
that it's it's a heartbreaking thing to
go through so yeah it's definitely
frustrating you know
like watching somebody like go to rehab
and then go back to it and then like
you know it's just frustrating but you
it's like my brother you're right it's
like I understand it's my artist but
it's like my real family and I'll be
[__] up if anything happened to him so
it's like I gotta put that first that
friendship you gotta put the human part
first before the artist should for the
industry should be good bro like that
was the most important part to me